the incoming president of the American
Academy of Pediatrics toured two CBP
facilities last week and tells CBS News
they are no place for children
dr. Saragossa received these pictures
from a social worker that were drawn by
children recently released from CBP
custody showing them in cages dr. Gosai
told us about the drawings and what she
witnessed inside the facilities when
they opened the door the first thing
that we that we that hit us was a smell
and there's a smell of sweat urine and
feces and I heard crinkling to my left
and I looked over there and there was a
sea of silver and there were young
children at boys and their unaccompanied
boys in there and they had no
expressions on their faces there was no
laughing no joking no talking I
described them almost like dog cages
with people in each of them in the
silence we're just hard to watch hard to
see dr. Sara goes there paints a
terrible picture and imagine the effect
it's gonna have on these kids for the
rest of their life here in the United
States of America there's just should
not be it's a devastating report by
every measure we as adults can debate
cages or not cages those drawings don't
tell the story about that